we are kicking off our in your
neighborhood series this morning here on
good day all month long we're going to
take you to different neighborhoods
across the valley
and this morning we will explore
chinatown the spring mountain corridor
it is jammed with asian shops and
restaurants
but as they shake off the pandemic
closures the same struggles seen all
across the valley this past year
are also impacting that vibrant part of
town john langler live at shanghai plaza
this morning
with a closer look at that hi john good
morning to you
good morning to you alex hopefully
everybody's doing well at home we are as
you mentioned live here at shanghai
plaza it's one of two new developments
in chinatown there's also
the green leaf lotus apartments right
near the freeway
this plaza right here which is pretty
well full opened in january of 2020.
now when shanghai plaza opened this was
an avenue for more
new investment to get a foothold into
las vegas's chinatown
it also brought more established asian
brands with more
international appeal to the neighborhood
adding to what's been along spring
mountain for decades
with the pandemic restrictions easing
business is picking up
but so is the demand for real estate we
spoke with long time realtor
and business owner grace tam about the
demand and what she thinks this area
needs
the prices on the
value on the land is really really
getting
very expensive i think infrastructure
the road is getting congested
we need the clark county to look into
this
if you've driven along spring mountain
during the day and especially at night
when all the restaurants are pretty full
the strip mall
parking lots are jammed in the streets
here spring mountain can get pretty
crowded too
one effect of the crowding is the
expansion of the asian community into
the southwest valley in henderson
many restaurants here along spring
mountain have second homes there
later this morning we're going to take a
closer look at how this neighborhood's
beloved restaurants have survived
the pandemic it has certainly been a
challenge for the asian community we
should also point out this is the
beginning of
aapi asian american pacific islander
heritage month
all across the country now you cannot go
far in chinatown without seeing the
positive impact
from some of the community organizations
including the ac dc the asian community
development council
the group is dedicated to improving all
aspects of life for
the aapi community in las vegas
yesterday members of the ac dc were in
carson city to meet with nevada
lawmakers
and they also attended an event at the
governor's mansion they met with the
first lady kathy sisolak it's one of the
first
public groups to make to be able to go
to the governor's mansion since the
pandemic started
ac dc works with legislators they lobby
up in carson city the
chamber of commerce for the asian
community was up there as well they
better understand how bills affect
the asian community and act as a voice
for them up in carson city
ac dc has also been working very hard to
get the coronavirus vaccine
here into the community in chinatown and
to the
at-risk parts of our valley last month
it partnered with immunized nevada
and they helped vaccinate more than 100
people right here in fact
at shanghai plaza which was hopefully
relatively convenient
now they picked this location because of
how fast the asian american community
is growing just right here in the heart
of our valley
council president vida lin says hosting
these clinics is especially important
for those who cannot drive long
distances or have language barriers
so when you get these pop up not only in
chinatown or asia town
but any other area that's where the
people is you're going to them
and they're going to a trusted group
that they've been working with
spoke with lynn a couple of a month or
so ago i guess it was she says that the
targeted vaccine approach is going to
continue
they're going to be having more pop-up
clinics in chinatown
as these those big mass vaccination
sites start to wind down we've been
of course reporting on that for some
time now we have a whole lot more coming
up from here in chinatown this morning
as we kick off our in your neighborhood
series this month
but coming up in the half hour at 6 30
or i'm going to show you the
diversity of businesses and restaurants
on the spring mountain corridor
and we'll talk about how they're
recovering from the covet 19 pandemic it
has been a challenge for them to get
through some of the stereotypes that was
taking place
during the pandemic as well and just the
effect on business we'll talk about the
recovery coming up later on this morning
alex back to you
uh john you have profiled so much there
it's good to see all that stuff
um and we're still waiting for that shop
to open yeah
50 minutes you and me both alex you and
me both
john i'm here too i'm just wondering
have you noticed a lot of growth because
you frequent chinatown a lot you love
asian food and you eat there often have
you noticed new restaurants that have
been popping up that you hadn't noticed
maybe pre-pandemic there's a couple
of new ones you talked to some of the
members of the chamber of commerce here
they said there's been
some ownership changes uh during the
pandemic and now
on the back end of the pandemic one of
the things when i spoke with grace tam
the local realtor she's been in the in
this community for a long long time
she points out as a lot of folks will
notice the southwest valley
is sort of another version of asia
chinatown the asian community in our
valley
a lot of restaurants that are here a lot
of businesses that are here
are also down there and she
would suggest and a lot of others would
suggest this is geared more towards
possibly the the strip
uh the visitors versus maybe the
southwestern parts of henderson which is
geared more towards the local community
that's not uncommon of course but the
problem is getting asian visitors back
to las vegas is still
almost impossible and they depend on
that a lot we'll talk about that of
course coming up at 6 30.
interesting all right john well hang in
there we'll see you here in about 20
minutes thank you so much for that
that's really good stuff